hallo das hört sich jetzt ein bisschen
blöd aber wir brauchen wirklich 28
pommes
[Musik]
ich weiß genau wo herzlich willkommen
beim neuen video leute ich hoffe euch
geht es gut das heutige video wollte ich
eigentlich erst morgen aufnehmen aber
ich werde praktisch gratis dazu
gezwungen ist jetzt zu machen man muss
aber auch dazu sagen dass es sich
vielleicht sogar lohnt es jetzt zu
machen weil wir dann auch wirklich
sofort abnehmer haben für das ganze
essen das jetzt gleich entstehen wird
beziehungsweise zu nehmen also abnehmer
von dem essen die dadurch immer zu
nehmen so wollte ich das sagen und zwar
habe ich mich heute was ganz ganz
besonders überlegt ich musste kurz etwas
aufmerksam machen
falls es doch nicht mitbekommen habt wir
haben hier eine supercoole verlosungs
ecke wir haben hier ein iphone wir haben
hier eine playstation wäre mir hieß es
wir haben hier lockenstab jetzt müsst
ihr untereinander sagen was man dafür
machen muss der hausmeister von erfahrt
ihr in meinem letzten videos also schaut
doch mal vorbei
ihr habt sie wahrscheinlich haben die
schon gelesen wir machen heute ein xxl
mcdonald's monopoly ich weiß nicht ob
das jeder von euch kennen mcdonald's hat
gerade diese coupons oder also sticker
die sind auf jeder grösseren
bestellungen drauf und da kann man etwas
gewinnen und ihr kennt mich natürlich
gerne hätte ich hin und kaufen noch ein
menü
nein wir kommen wir jetzt 400 euro ein
und haben dann ungefähr 200 oder 300
liter also das sind praktisch wieso
rubbellose und da kann man halt auch
fette samen gewinnen aber ich will er
sofort gewinne haben egal wer schon mal
was bei rumkommt die werden
zwei hälften julius echter also mein
mitbewohner was kaufen jetzt ein
wie viel komik 30 wie kaufe jetzt 28 6
28 uhr eschweiler moment haben soll
und dazu kommt auch drei große co
ich will gar nicht lange lagern genau
wir fangen jetzt an und fahren los bis
gleich was meinst du wie viele pommes
chips so groß ist dass nach 34
ich bin jetzt mal gespannt ob die uns
jetzt wirklich 30 pommes machen und wie
lange das dauert das wir auch soll der
fall wenn es so seit heute nicht mehr
hallo das hört sich jetzt ein bisschen
blöd haben aber wir brauchen wirklich 28
pommes große pommes
ja ja das ist uns klar
langsam kommen wie lange wird ja wie
lange dauert das ungefähr ja okay das
passt genau 28 mal ist das schon dann so
sie dabei ach so ja dann nehmen wir noch
mal 50 mal 50 stationen fünfmal sich
aber betrübt und dazu kommen dann noch
zweimal und
salzburg naja das machst du das machst
du und dann noch vier große kohle wenig
24 jahren das klare ja was an
okay wir haben jetzt 99 56 fast 100 euro
so ich habe noch den polit plan geholt
die macht mehr drin halt echt gerade als
voll action wegen und dann kommen konnte
[Musik]
so wie sich das gehört so alles schön
ineinander
[Musik]
hey das ist unfassbar wie kann man sogar
die bahn habe ich gute jetzt ja dass sie
dir nur halt machen du hast viel kilo
kommen
[Musik]
so leute ihr fragt euch sicherlich warum
das ganze jetzt schon längst wir haben
uns nicht komplett selber geschafft wir
haben locker noch 25 promise ich denke
wir haben so 5 selber gegessen haben wir
alles noch eine tüte gepackt und haben
dass obdachlose auf der straße geben ist
ja eigentlich das coolste was man machen
kann ich finde das sollte jeder machen
immer wenn es irgendwas mit essen zu tun
hat ich persönlich finde solche videos
mega unterhalts haben viele von euch ja
sicherlich auf nur man sollte das erst
dann auf keinen fall wegschmeißen klar
mcdonald's ist jetzt nicht mehr gesund
das gefühl man sich darüber freuen wir
haben das ganze auch gefallen bzw
die mädels also mal kurz ein blick
[Musik]
jetzt will ich sagen kommen wir aber zum
hauptthema dieses videos wir haben jetzt
30 verschiedenen wir haben sogar 35
verschiedene produkte wenn diese nur
politikern rauch und hier haben wir das
monopol fällt muss jetzt mal kurz gucken
wie man das gesinnt aber jetzt muss man
eben die einstecken nicht wünscht
eingelagert
wir haben sofort man das erste und also
an der bahnhofstraße und hauptbahnhof
sowie wollen jahr war die sofortgewinne
oder den jackpot so und da geht's auch
schon los jackpot
ich hatte aber noch nie ein jackpot und
ich schon voll aufrecht hin zu online
team geben hast du das mal gemacht ja
hab nichts gewonnen so denn da war ich
wie man hier auch noch roger die
schlossallee beschloss die beste wir
haben hier noch höher als wenn junge
will es so wir haben hier jackpot korte
ja das kann auch nicht sein als wenn
alles nur über jackpot ist hat dieser
mensch ist nur jackpot kurz oder was ich
mache es so wenn menschen das wirklich
gewinnen wollten wie oft gehen die denn
da essen theaterstraße und hauptmann
hatte ich schon brauche ich nicht noch
mal als wenn ich noch gar kein
sofortgewinnen hat und wir haben einen
jackpot als wenn alles voll mit jackpot
coaches und schlossallee scheint ja auch
nicht selten zu sein so fort ja klar
stellt daher stelle ich mal kommen auch
nicht aus
und das ist auch okay sektor so eine
seestraße hast du schon jetzt haben
stimmt fuhrleute juli hilft jetzt habe
ich das nicht und bahnhofstraße
sofortgewinnen eine com ist klein oder
ein café smart dann nehme ich dir
gedacht warum europa nun ist nicht der
roboter ist neun jahre alt ist wird man
jetzt über aufgeklebte ich habe sofort
gewinnen würde so jetzt mache ich mal
hier das getränk offen sofortgewinnen
eine pommes klein sie sind aber auch
geistig mit jackpot jackpot
da kann das sein weil ich einfach nur
promis gewollt habe dass auch puma ist
immer jackpot sind die folge wenn eine
eistüte oder ein loch wie er sie so ein
lobbyist die ganzen einfach
sofortgewinne kopatschek seestraße sich
auch schon bald ist ja das gericht habe
ich schon beides gehört bahnhof
bahnhofstraße gleichen straße schon bald
ja wort wie einklang mit videos von hier
kann man nicht kann man da überhaupt
oscars gewinnen so als sofortgewinn ein
jackpot wir wollen wir die jackpot
gleich ein leben ja fünfmal
kabelgebunden sofortgewinnen 1
einschießt doch was wird davon kann sich
eine wochen wieder von mails sofort wenn
alle pommes klein und badstraße waren
wir mal so ein treffen ankündigen bei
rec ist und alle die kommen kriegen
unsere sofortgewinne ja okay leute als
ihr habt gehört sofort gewinnt eine form
ist klein oder eine körperstelle
vorankommen 5
530 sofortgewinne ja leute waren immer
vorgehabt dass wir wieder in friedberg
ist machen darum nach sofort gewählt ein
cappuccino 201 max handelt das wird sich
noch der letzte rest haben wir keine
mehr
das ist jetzt echt jetzt du kannst
dieses feld nicht folglich musste da
jeden tag 5 - essen und in echt nix was
du hast etwas wichtiges übersehen
und jetzt ist hier der der absolute
jackpot sofort in ein hamburger
cheeseburger wo man dachte ich habe
jetzt echt wirklich kopf dafür 100 euro
ein ich dachte ich an welchen shops und
irgendwas kassel okay leute ich würde
sagen wir geben jetzt mal die ganzen
jackpot kurze ein und dann was krasses
haben melden uns gleich wieder
jetzt gewinnen auto sechseinhalb stunden
später um michaels 14 jackpot codes
eingeben und immer steht für bewusste
genuss bereits 14 jackpot kurz eingelöst
erhöhte gewinnchance auf dem wie viel
solche noch kaufen 100 euro rabatt von
100 euro eingekauft da musst du ja
gerade mal ob du musst hier pro monat
jeden tag da essen um auf 100 euro
zukommen
das ist aber nicht gesund ich habe jetzt
ja schon eine woche gemacht das war auf
jeden fall nicht gesund also ich bin
jetzt um ehrlich zu sein echt ein
bisschen enttäuscht natürlich kann es
sein dass wir hier noch eine tolle
bestätigung bekommen dass wir irgendwie
in drei wochen und diesen jackpot
gewonnen haben was ich nicht glaube
aber ich bin jetzt auf jeden fall um
hundert euro ärmer wir haben paar pommes
verschenkt zwar auf jeden fall cool hat
spaß gemacht und für was sagen sofort
wenn im wert von zehn euro sind dabei
welches die liebe fahrer lassen doch
nach oben da machen sehen wir uns wieder
schreibt in die kommentare für videos
eher um 1519 von mir sehen wollten die
witterungslage haut rein das war dass
ich noch eine kugel kaputtmachen
wiederkommst mal